It doesn't matter if I use medium roast or light roast for my animals.
No, they don't work exactly the same, so the light roast, the golden roast that we have,
that we sell in our store is specifically for animals. You wouldn't drink that.
It's not roasted very much at all because the lighter the roast, the more caffeine it,
the more it's going to stimulate the parasympathetics.
Now, again, if you're doing my easy peasy animal prescription that's on the membership site,
you're just, you just roasting any coffee, you know, it's just, hey, that's better than doing nothing.
So don't get too hung up on that. Don't beat yourself. Oh, I got to get this.
This is going to be the magic secret is going to get this light roast. No.
So if you're just doing the coffee animals, I don't care if you're using Starbucks.
But use that organic blend will be best.